should we bring back the death
penalty oo that's a difficult one isn't
it if you'd have asked me this 20 years
ago without doubt I'd have said
absolutely yes and I'd have probably
been the first to volunteer to do the
Death Watch maybe I've gone a bit soft
in my old age but I'm not so sure that
that is the right way to go these days
yes there are some horrendous evil
crimes um that happen these days but is
it really as a society do we want to
take that step backwards I'm not so sure
that we do there have been a lot of
miscarriages of Justice over the last
couple of years and I don't know how we
as a society would live with ourselves
if we executed the wrong person